>>> JUST A HANDFUL OF RACES ARE
GOING TO DETERMINE WHICH PARTY
WILL CONTROL THE SENATE.
CNN'S SENIOR DATA REPORTER HARRY
ENTON IS HERE TO RUN THE
NUMBERS.
WHERE DO WE STAND ON THE MOST
PIVOTAL RACES FOR SENATE?
>> I FEEL WE'VE DONE THIS EVERY
WEEKEND.
WE'RE GETTING CLOSER AND CLOSER
TO ELECTION DAY AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THINGS ARE GETTING TIGHTER
AND TIGHTER AND TIGHTER.
SO LOOK, THIS IS THE DEMOCRATS'
ROAD TO KEEPING 50 SENATE SEATS.
THEY LIKELY MUST WIN THREE OF
THESE FOUR WITHIN MARGIN OF
ERROR RACES.
THE EASIEST LOOKS LIKE ARIZONA.
MARK KELLY, INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT,
UP BY 3 POINTS.
THAT'S WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
LOOK HOW CLOSE PENNSYLVANIA AND
GEORGIA ARE.
1-POINT RACES.
FETTERMAN UP, WARNOCK UP BY A
POINT, WAY TOO CLOSE TO CALL.
NEVADA IS TIED.
AT THIS POINT GEORGIA WOULD BE
THE 50th SENATE SEAT IF THE
POLLS WERE EXACTLY RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS WOULD KEEP THEIR
MAJORITY BY THE THINNEST OF THIN
MARGINS.
AGAIN, WELL WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
AREA, JUST REALLY TIGHT.
>> AS WE KNOW, POLLS AREN'T
ALWAYS EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT'S INTERESTING, THESE THREE IS
WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER SAID IN HIS
HOT MIC MOMENT, WHOEVER WINS TWO
OF THESE THREE WILL HAVE THE
MAJORITY.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
GEORGIA, SUCH AN INTERESTING
RACE.
BEEN A LOT OF DRAMA THERE
SURROUNDING HERSCHEL WALKER.
SCARING OFF POTENTIAL VOTERS?
DO VOTERS NOT CARE?
>> LOOKS LIKE VOTERS DON'T CARE.
TAKE A LOOK, WE'LL DIVIDE THIS.
MY SLOW DRAW DOWN THE LINE.
TODAY VERSUS OCTOBER 1st.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE SEE IS THERE
ARE MORE UNDECIDED VOTERS, 47%
FOR WARNOCK, 46% FOR WALKER.
LOOK AT THIS, 3% FOR CHASE
OLIVER.
WE NEVER REALLY TALK ABOUT
LIBERTARIAN CANDIDATES.
WHY DO I HAVE THAT CANDIDATE ON
THE SCREEN?
THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE IN
GEORGIA, YOU NEED 50% OF THE
VOTE PLUS ONE IN ORDER TO
ADVANCE OR WIN THE RACE WITHOUT
A RUNOFF.
AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT, WE
WOULD, IN FACT, PROBABLY BE
HEADING TOWARDS A RUNOFF, WHICH
WOULD NOT OCCUR UNTIL ALL THE
WAY IN DECEMBER.
SO IF IT COMES DOWN TO GEORGIA,
WE MIGHT NOT KNOW WHO HAS WON
SENATE CONTROL UNTIL DECEMBER,
WHICH MEANS WE CAN HAVE MORE FUN
ON SATURDAY NIGHTS.
>> KEEPING YOU IN BUSINESS.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE BARACK
OBAMA ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HE WAS JUST SPEAKING IN
MILWAUKEE.
WILL HE BE AN EFFECTIVE
SURROGATE?
>> YES, SO I THINK THE QUESTION
IS WHY WOULD YOU TROT OUT THE
OLD, OLD PRESIDENT?
HE LEFT OFFICE BACK IN 2017.
NEARLY SIX YEARS AGO, MY
GOODNESS, HOW DOES TIME FLY?
I REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS ELECTED,
I WAS IN COLLEGE, THINGS HAVE
REALLY GONE -- BUT HERE'S THE
REASON WHY.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS FAVORABLE
RATING.
57% NATIONALLY.
HIS UNFAVORABLE RATING AT 38%.
HE'S THE MOST POPULAR GUY THEY
COULD REALLY PUT OUT THERE, PAM.
JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING IS
BASICALLY IN THE LOW 40s.
DONALD TRUMP, THE FORMER
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT, OBVIOUSLY
HIS FAVORABLE RATING IS IN THE
LOW 40s.
THIS IS THE GUY YOU WANT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HE'S AT LEAST PROBABLY NOT GOING
TO ALIENATE ANYBODY, AND HE'S
SOMEBODY WHO PERHAPS WILL RALLY
TROOPS.
>> AS WE KNOW, BARACK OBAMA,
LOOK AT HIS APPROVAL RATINGS
WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
HE SUFFERED A MAJOR SEAT LOSS IN
HIS FIRST MIDTERM, AND A LOT OF
AMERICANS THINK THE COUNTRY WAS
ON THE WRONG TRACK.
THERE IS A PATTERN THERE.
HOW ABOUT NOW?
>> YEAH, SO TAKE A LOOK HERE.
SATISFIED WITH THE WAY THINGS
ARE GOING IN THE U.S. AT THIS
POINT IN YOUR FIRST MIDTERM.
LOOK, I THINK WE WOULD LOVE IF
47% OF THE COUNTRY WERE
SATISFIED WITH THE WAY THINGS
ARE GOING.
IN FACT, WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
IN THE LATEST GALLUP POLL, JUST
21% OF AMERICANS ARE SATISFIED
WITH THE WAY THINGS ARE GOING IN
THE U.S.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT FIRST
MIDTERMS, ALL THE WAY BACK SINCE
1982, THAT IS THE LOWEST
PERCENTAGE.
RIGHT NEARBY, YOU WERE HINTING
AT IT, 22% BACK IN OCTOBER 2010
RECALL BARACK OBAMA'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SUFFERED A MAJOR SEAT LOSS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
LOST 63 SEATS, EVEN IN THE
SENATE WHERE THEY HAD MORE ROOM
TO LOSE, THEY STILL LOST SIX
SEATS IN THE U.S. SENATE.
THE FACT IS THIS COMPARISON
BETWEEN OCTOBER OF 2010 AND
SEPTEMBER OF 2022 IS NOT THE
TYPE OF COMPARISONS THAT
DEMOCRATS NECESSARILY WANT.
BUT HEY, MAYBE BARACK OBAMA WITH
HIS HIGH FAVORABLE RATING CAN
BRING IN MORE VOTERS.
>> HALLOWEEN IS ON MONDAY.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DRESS UP
AS?
THE BIG QUESTION, THE BURNING
QUESTION.
>> WHAT AM I GOING TO DRESS UP
AS?
I'M NOT REALLY SURE.
I ALREADY KIND OF THINK I'M
QUITE OF CARD.
SO MAYBE I'LL JUST DRESS UP AS
MYSELF.
MAYBE I'LL WEAR A TIE AND LOOK
LIKE I BELONG ON TELEVISION FOR
A CHANGE.
>> WHAT ABOUT CARVING PUMPKINS
OR WATCHING SCARY MOVIES?
>> WHAT DO YOU DO DURING THE
HALLOWEEN SEASON?
39% OF AMERICANS, THAT'S THE TOP
THING, SAY THEY DECORATE THEIR
HOUSE.
MAYBE I'M CARVE A PUMPKIN, 37%.
WATCHA SCARY MOVIE, 36%.
DRESS UP 32,%, NOT ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO A MAJORITY.
VISIT A KIN PATCH AT 26%.
GO TRICK-OR-TREATING, I THINK I
NEED A KID DO THAT, AT MY AGE.
>> NO, YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
YOU LOOK -- I MEAN THIS AS A
COMPLIMENT.
I FEEL YOU COULD GET BY.
>> I'M A LITTLE TALL.
IF I SHAVE?
>> IF YOU SHAVE, I THINK YOU
COULD GO TRICK-OR-TREATING BY
YOURSELF WITHOUT A KID.
>> I'M NOT SURE I'M THAT MUCH OF
A LOSER, JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
ONE.
>> I VISITED A PUMPKIN PATCH,
IT'S A LOT OF FUN, HIGHLY
RECOMMENDED.
>> MAYBE I'LL DO THAT.
>> I'LL BE CARVING TOMORROW.
>> YOU HAVE A FULFILLING LIFE.
I, ON THE OTHER HAND, DON'T
REALLY.
>> NOT TRUE, HARRY HINTO